welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of miss
marvel episode one which makes us wonder
why are the only superpowers i leave
banned conventions with sunburn and
covid let's break down this first
episode shot by shot for the many mcu
easter eggs and details that you might
have missed and i was fortunate this
time to talk to the directors of this
episode a dylan bella who gave me some
exclusive insights that i will be
including in this breakdown the marvel
studios title card has now been updated
with a shot of doctor strange from
multiverse madness and then on the m
it's our main moon night over this we
hear the weeknd's blinding lights a
tease for the aesthetics of this series
many shots have blinding lens flares of
the same kind of purple fuchsia color of
miss marvel's hard light in the weird
realm that she goes to and it is
literally blinding light that activates
kamala's powers at the convention all of
this reflecting how kamala
metaphorically finds herself blinded by
the light of her own new cosmic powers
both how cool they are and the burden of
being a superhero this opening sequence
is i love it a youtube video as kamala
uses her drawings to recap the events of
adventures in-game now kamala khan first
appeared as a fan of captain marvel
carol danvers in a 2013 captain marvel
comic and then shortly after got her own
spin-off in 2014 from writer g willow
wilson that explored her point of view
as a pakistani american muslim teenager
in jersey city and really a total marvel
stan that all one step removed fandom is
at the heart of this character and why
so many comics readers as marvel fans
ourselves could connect with her and
it's just so great that this series
opens with a marvel fan video i feel
seen iman valani herself is an mcu nerd
who carries around with her a notebook
filled with mcu notes and questions who
i found out in the press conference is a
big fan of this channel might be
watching right now i hope so all this to
say this opening feels super authentic
we start with kamala's drawings
including grouchy hulk and then hands
together with bismala an expression
meaning in the name of god an expression
that characters say throughout this
episode we see her flying sloth and then
bigfoot with his nether regions and
upper regions covered by stars kamala
says this is a 10 part series on earth's
mightiest hero using the avengers
moniker but describing captain marvel's
savior role in in-game we see drawings
of cap iron man hulk black panther thick
thor and okoye slaying thanos's forces
and the final charge of end game hawkeye
is using a rubber band bow flinging
thumbtacks there's a post-it note
listing captain marvel sightings sandy
beaches tokyo dark alley in an arena
marla says the avengers were losing at
this point in battle and she's not wrong
it was really in all his last moment
when captain marvel showed up i like how
we see the main avengers joined by wanda
maximov ant-man valkyrie and pepper
potts's rescue and we see cap's shield
broken molly says thanos was being a
jerk about magical stones of course
referring to the infinity stones we see
his warship with boo you suck on a note
in the corner we hear an eagle screech
over a bird with a carol danvers mohawk
right below that is a drawing
approximate midnight and then we see
carol's fighter jet and carol flying
past a sign that reads the future is
female then some comics art of captain
marvel flying through space and kamala
drags an ms paint file of captain marvel
across her desktop screen what
generation of computer is she using and
i love it kamala mentioned studying
scott lang's podcast it's called big me
little me on this powered life which
must be a parody of this american life
that does interviews with superheroes in
the mcu suggesting that this superhero
confessional podcast was how the public
of the mcu learned of everything the
avengers did during the infinity war and
in-game events and this might have been
what informed paul greengrass's film the
snap that we saw on the inflate movie
screen in spider-man far from home just
a cool little detail that actually tells
us a lot about the mcu now when i asked
the director it's the dylan bilal about
other avengers having podcasts in the
mcu here's what they had to say do you
think any other avengers might have a
podcast series other than scott lang
why it would be it would be great to i
mean i would love to know what the hulk
you know what his podcast is you know
that or deadpool i mean deadpool would
be funny i think imagine you have
deadpool and blades doing uh during a
podcast again that would be pretty cool
you heard it here folks mcu cannon
played in deadpool have a podcast
together i think we should call it steak
chimichanga steak spelled s-t-a-k-e
kamala recaps how in in-game carol flew
directly through thanos fleet also how
she changed her hair for this return and
she did take on thanos one by one kamala
does leave out though how carol davis
got walloped pretty hard with the power
stone i like how cap and scott lang are
seen with actual band-aids on them and
you can see how their torn limbs are
taped back together with scotch tape
kamala addresses how carol the cosmic
avenger is not on earth currently we're
calling roadie calling carol out an end
game and setting up whatever the plot
will be for when kamala khan joins
monica rambo and carol danvers in the
film the marvels here we see photos of
kamala's friends bruno and nakia and her
brother amir and in this animation when
carol returns at the avenger con beside
a capped shield is a war machine head
winking over at a carol head smooching
which is a nod to the romance between
these two characters in the comics and
maybe in the mcu i mean they had that
moment where they looked at each other
in endgame and thank you to better help
for sponsoring this video if you think
you might be feeling depressed stressed
anxious or overwhelmed betterhelp is
here to help betterhelp offers licensed
therapists who are trained to listen and
to help you message your therapist in a
private online environment at your
convenience there is a broad range of
expertise and better helps over 20 000
therapists network that gives you access
to help that may not be available in
your area you fill out a questionnaire
to help assess your specific needs and
then you get matched with the therapist
in under 48 hours then you schedule
secure video and phone sessions plus you
can exchange unlimited messages and
everything you share is completely
confidential you can request a new
therapist at no additional charge
anytime join the two million plus people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with an experienced better health
therapist get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com new rockstars or click
the link in the description that's b e t
t e r h e l p dot com slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month
kamahala says she has a two-part series
on why thor is secretly a gamer a
reference of course to thor playing
fortnite in in-game and she says new
episodes drop every wednesday a nod to
how this series drops on wednesdays her
youtube channel is sloth baby
productions two subscribers oh you'll
get there must be bruno and nakia since
they both leave comments on this video
now the miss marvel press conference
included me asking iman villani directly
if kamala khan subscribed to new
rockstars and she said that she wasn't
sure but probably at least a variant of
us so sweet of bird to be so kind to us
we love you amon especially since you
know the artists of the show here we're
citing new rock stars with these
thumbnails and video titles truth
revealed on the real carol danvers story
ant-man the wasps romantic vacation in
paris i like how that flying ant has a
beret and then where did she get her
powers bitten by a radioactive feminist
on this day kamala wears a shirt reading
ladies let's get information we have
captain marvel valkyrie and wasp
parodying the beyonce song and we need
her family her brother amir her father
yusuf and her mother moniba of the three
i like how yusuf is the rule breaker he
tells amir to pray less he tells kamala
to skip stop signs and fake looking in
the mirror but the first thing kamala
does on her driving test after buckling
in mirror check with the aviators and
it's clear that she is thinking to
herself higher for the faster baby which
may be also why she floors the gas the
driving instructor is played by randy
havens aka mr clark from stranger things
the directors of the series say that
they were inspired by spider-man into
the spider-verse and like that movie
does the opening titles here flash
through more of kamala khan's art
showing a comic cover drawn by her
jersey city comics approved by the kkk
code kamala khan code i get a little
nervous when i see multiple k's back to
back but we'll look past that in this
comic issue she battles the something
king and on the page behind this are
more drawings showing scott lang and
kamala's mutated human man ant as
kamala's parents drive her home monina
says this is my fault this is all my
fault these are my genetics i mean i
come from a long line of fantasizing on
yeah little clue here pointing to kamala
in her mother's family history
specifically maniva's mother as the
source of the powers that kamala gains
kamala attends kohl's academic high
school where the founders are all comics
writers and artists most crucial to the
creation of the malacon character of
course g willow wilson the miss marvel
comics writer i mentioned before stephen
wacker marvel animated producer behind
many of kamala's comic team-ups adrian
alfona an artist on the first kamala run
jamie mckelvey an artist who helped
relaunch carol danvers and designed
kamala khan's first miss marvel outfit
ian herring known for titles like miss
marvel and silk especially takeshi
miyazawa another artist who worked on
the kamala run joe caramanga a marvel
comics writer on several titles over the
years and nico leon another artist who
worked on the kamala comics i love that
they get a shout out here i just you
know hope that disney pays them all a
little bonus too we meet kamala's
friends bruno corelli and nakia bahadir
and the popular girl to school zoe
zimmer all of these from this particular
run of the comics around the score signs
reading dustin for prez he is a very
good choice dustin berry was the guy who
worked in the set department for the
show and a number of mcu titles kamala
meets with guidance counselor gabe
wilson i assume named after g willow
wilson gw is written on his desk
organizer a quick montage of kamala's
mishaps all show flashes of light the
dodgeball hit the chemistry explosion
the sunlight beaming in on the art
teacher kamala is blinded by the light
at the beginning setting her up to
eventually control and master the light
mr wilson motivates kamala with the
lyrics of reflection from mulan i'm not
gonna lie high school staff could do
worse than just recite disney lyrics to
kids he says i know fantasy's fun
fantasy is really fun but right now i
need you to pull yourself together
and join reality i like how this split
screen reflects how divided kamala is
right now staying grounded in reality or
escaping into her dreams and fantasies
her path forward is in the ladder the
circle q shop shows up kamala's home
base in this run of the comics she and
bruno plan to go to avengers con which
is a lot like the 8 a celebration in the
avengers game which leads to kamala khan
getting her powers in san francisco the
graffiti they bike past all comes to
light it looks amazing visualizing their
final flourish pitches we see steampunk
captain marvel mashups captain panther
or iron marvel they end up in a cat
fight then doctor strange marvel comes
in from a portal and makes that same
fanned out arm pose as the images of
icon spell that we saw infinity war and
the souls of the damned and multiverse
madness then captain marvel on a pegasus
like valkyrie road and in-game and jane
rides in thor 4 then princess captain
marvel who changes the graffiti word to
shine then zombie captain marvel her
thumb falls off i love that and when
they are all rejected they all look
really sad like you can see steampunk
ghost taking her hat off interesting now
kamala watches an episode of felicity
like where is that playing on tv and
syndication anywhere but then kamala's
upside down world turns right side up on
this delivery from hernani showing how
what's inside that box is really the
answer that will straighten out her life
the bengal an artifact that meniba has
definitely seen before and immediately
tells amir to hide in the attic when you
think about it this whole afternoon with
kamala and her mom must have been
unplanned like originally munibo was
going to go wedding shopping with amir
but she took kamala to take him all his
mind off of the bengal and off of her
grandmother now there are a lot of ways
we could read this bangle exactly what
it is for now it could be an analog of
the cree nega band that transports
mar-vell to the negative zone or maybe
the quantum bands worn by quasar to fire
energy blasts i actually think this is
some extraterrestrial tech there is some
indecipherable writing and a symbol that
looks like a starburst but really more
importantly for kamala i think it's
something connected to her family
history they get home and greet bruno
i'll back you something to go no no i'm
good hey how was it
don't mention belgium oh any guy named
rob did you ask her about a venture card
there's a spicy one at the bottom for no
now oh my gosh how did you do that so
fast whoa so i timed it out mouniba put
that to-go bag together in 10 seconds if
it's meant to be just a super mom gag
you don't really see me eva do this
anywhere else i'm just saying it could
just be a joke for the mom or the women
of this family might have something
going on with them her parents refused
to let her attend avenger con and amir
checks in on her asking if she's still
afraid of the gin jins are spirits and
demons in arabic mythology the term and
concept later anglicized as genie she
claims to no longer be afraid of the
dark but she does use a starlight
projector thing in her bedroom don't
worry kamala having a healthy fear of
demons is just part of being a true
marvel fan
the poster behind her bed shows captain
marvel from jerry dodson's cover of the
comic captain marvel number five it
really just seems like they pulled every
awesome looking comics image of captain
marvel and put it on her bedroom walls i
like how kamala's text appears in the
star lights of her ceiling whereas
bruno's response takes the form of the
street paint as the taxi drives over it
but in addition to the vfx animation i
like how they did this practically by
igniting the neon signs in the store
windows and then the led marquis showing
their ellipses and their emojis kamala's
parents try to compromise that kamala
can go to a venture con with her dad
with her as little hulk him as big hulk
which i would love to have my parents
offer to do this with me i don't think
i'd find it embarrassing but i get it
kamala says it'd be humiliating and
there's a huge missed opportunity here
to have use of sadly walk out to the 80s
hulk theme
like yeah wouldn't that have been
awesome i mean they did use this track
in the 2008 hulk film
bruno references the time when kamala
fell into the hudson river which is
something that happens to zoe zimmer in
the comics that leads to kamala's first
superpowered rescue kamala and bruno sit
on the roof their feet dangling by an
iron man sign but looks a bit blurred
and that might have been because the
show's producers were told to tone down
the numerous iron man references they
were gonna make but actually if you look
really closely you could barely make out
that this is really an iron man themed
cereal called iron bran behind them is a
sign for edison electric with these bolt
images which might be teasing kamala's
eventual logo of a lightning bolt he
gives her these gloves for her cosplay
are those photon gloves yeah yes photon
is capitalized in closed captioning
meaning that they are referring to
monica rambo photon from her mother
maria's call sign she goes by both
photon and spectrum in the comics but
one division never actually named her so
she's now confirmed as photon and
apparently enough of a public figure for
kamala and bruno to know about her and
her powers which is interesting now the
directors had this to say about the
photon easter egg how do they know who
monica rambo is i want to ask you guys
thoughts on that yeah
whenever we would ask a question like
that to kevin feige he would say i don't
answer that i'll say that
we will see and discover like anybody
else because we were all saying so what
happens in the marvels actually
and and or or you know dr strange or
spiderman and he would only say no if
there's a problem i'll tell you and i
don't tell you why so
just
so to me that sounds like it might have
been a deliberate inclusion by the
studio to set up kamala's coming
crossover with monica and carol kamala
breaks down her elaborate plan to bruno
to get to avengers con in her fantasy
her cosplay is actual mcu wardrobe
standard and she does a black widow
landing outer window the pose something
that the show's producers said kamala
would know as one of the few female
superheroes she grew up seeing footage
of bruno in this fantasy cosplays as
tony stark wearing sunglasses a goatee
and a blowing chest reactor avenger con
is at camp lehigh that's the new jersey
base where steve rogers trained where
steve and black widow returned to him
winter soldier and cap and tony visited
in 1970 and in game on the bus in this
fantasy are cosplayers of the star
spangled dancers and loki and a sorcerer
with a shield among all the fantasy
selfies are a pipe or cylindrical rocket
raccoon and nick fury vision needing a
pretzel and it ends with kamala dreaming
of getting a tiara something that she
rejected earlier when bruno pitched
princess captain marvel and then the set
transitions practically into an upright
bed which is the same camera trick of
the nexus anti-depressant commercial in
wonder vision and while kamala's plan
ultimately goes awry she does in the
night dropping into bed yes his dream
plan immediately falls apart instead of
a superhero landing out her window she
breaks the tree branch and falls hard
that was the way she was gonna get back
into her room really the only way she's
able to get back into her window is with
the help of that hard light that she's
later able to summon poor bruno even his
outfit doesn't look as cool we learned
later his whole cosplay is just a white
lab coat for bruce banner this poor guy
spent way more time making kamala's
cosplay suit than he did his own we all
need friends like bruno but instead we
don't talk about food
the camp lehigh banner is actually
similar to the sign of the gate when
tony and cap arrived in 1970 an end game
they added capped shield in the middle
of it and i like how they put this large
statue of captain america in a jeep you
listen to the music playing in the scene
it is the star spangled man with the
plan i like the little dance that the
guy in the wakandan garb does to
celebrate his awesome looking fit inside
the convention booths include things
hulk smashed which i guess is just a
collection of rubble and broken stuff
from all of hulk's collateral damage
over the years you can see a fridge with
a giant handprint in it there's a giant
man scott lang display with a fairy in a
pool recreating his size up in the san
francisco bay and ant-man and the wasp
there's a cosmic avenger captain marvel
setup there's a realm of asgard with a
thor throne that you can sit on we see
the iron man dancers from the stark expo
in iron man 2 mugs of mjolnir ale some
art pieces referencing america's ass i
understood that reference then there's a
memorial wall for the fallen with
messages to various loved ones pinned up
to it in the middle is natasha and tony
on display but no vision also in the
upper right of all the notes is a
mention of the sekovia accords i assume
someone's saying this is why we need the
second accords hey hey why you gotta
make this so political bro there's
another booth with a guy dressed as drax
showing a dvd on sale the peter quill
star boy story pal to all planets a
40-minute documentary series i like how
the title calls him star boy keeping up
with the recurring gag of messing up his
name it isn't star prince
star-lord oh sorry presumably if quill
himself would have been the source for
this they probably would have gotten his
name right so i'm guessing this is a
third party trying to cash in on it also
in the background is a shelf with rocket
plushies labeled trash pandas because
that's what he is he is a trash panda is
that better
i don't know
it's so much worse another guy hands out
pamphlets for avenger tours to new
asgard which might be part of the
tourist attractions that we are now
seeing in thor love and thunder footage
now here's a fun one after kamala leaves
the bathroom there is a cardboard
captain america and a cardboard iron man
on the left of the frame which were
actually cameos by sagar shaikh and rish
shah who play amir and cameron thanks to
sauger friend of the show who actually
sent me a photo of him in rish on set
kamala is able to unlock the bangle by
twisting a small circle that turns four
other cogs and then it clips on and
extends then coats her body with a layer
of cosmic radiation and then she falls
backward into this interesting purple
tinted realm filled with shadowy figures
their eyes glowing many of them look
bald and caped carrying spears i don't
know they look a bit like watchers a
statue of whom appears in thor 4. now if
this bangle is based on the cree nega
bands we might be looking at the
negative zone but i think this is gonna
be more personal to kamala and her
family hernani the purple and fuchsia
tones actually remind me a lot of the
ancestral plane which moon knight just
told us is part of the same mcu
afterlife network as the egyptian
underworld we could be looking at
another spiritual realm that's connected
with the ancestors of the con women
ancestors who might be extraterrestrial
cree or skrull or korea experiments on
the humans the inhumans because in the
comics kamala gets her powers by being
enveloped in terrigen mist a process
called terogenesis that creates inhumans
and in her terrigen cocoon she sees the
forms of cap in iron man and captain
marvel and comes out in a form modeled
on her idol carol danvers but with
stretchy limbs before she realizes that
she could just look like herself in
marvel lore the inhumans are genetic
experiments by decree and in the mcu the
crease frame intelligence uses tech in
which its form manifests based on the
perceiver's inner desires so kamala's
cosmic powers from this bangle may still
be cree or inhuman in origin but coming
to kamala by way of her pakistani
grandmother who maybe could have been an
extraterrestrial refugee on earth with
alien technology to harness the power of
the cosmos to manifest one's inner
desires in fact this layer of cosmic
radiation whisping around her body could
be the mcu's version of terrigen mist
i'm just doing my best to theorize how
this works we'll learn more in future
episodes now as she takes a stage light
is what triggers her powers to activate
the flashing camera and as she is
blinded by the light she emits a series
of crystalline discs what the show calls
hard light the same colors of the realm
she fell into now yes this is the change
from kamala's powers in the comics in
which she can stretch and embig in her
limbs like reed richards can but the
producers have said that they want to
better align mcu kamala with where the
mcu currently is that seems to be either
cosmic radiation of captain marvel and
photon and the cree or maybe a kind of
mystical light inherited from her
grandmother or really again as i think a
mix of the two one blast of these knocks
the giant man helmet loose so that this
thing boulders through the convention
rude goldberging the avengers boost so
that a giant mjolnir swings right into
zoey think about it for gamala this is
her worst nightmare something that she
did causing the collapse of every
avenger before her eyes in the comics
kamala's first hero moment is saving
zoey and begging her hand to lift her
from the hudson river here she uses a
cosmic extension of her hand and arm to
cushion zoe's fall actually in the
closing credits of this episode you can
see an embiggened version of kamala's
hand catching zoe as it looks in the
comics the animation on the house as
kamala gets home shows the time as 11 11
which is the time one makes a wish a nod
to kamala going through a bit of wish
fulfillment here her mother catches her
sneaky back in do you want to be good
like we raised you to be
or or do you want to be some you know
this cosmic
head in the clouds person
and dropping back down on her bed come
all the answers
yes this decision comes to kamala
falling backward just as she did when
she first snapped on that bengal and
fell into her what i think ancestral
netherworld and when you think back to
the earlier scene this reaffirms her
accidental reverse on the driving test
as exactly the right direction for her
moving backward but really just to give
herself a runway to launch into the
cosmos the closing credits have a few
more fun easter eggs kamala's iconic red
converses and her scarf from the comics
we see a trust a bro moving truck from
hawkeye and we see the same kamala khan
yellow bolt on purple t-shirt design
from the comics now there's a quick shot
of a skyscraper with the vestiges of the
avengers tower quinjet landing pad but
it's a new facade this is no longer
avengers tower i would say this could be
the baxter building but multiverse of
madness showed the baxter foundation in
central park then again that was eight
three eight this is six one six even
though iman velani vocally disagrees
with kevin feige on the mcu's numerical
designation i'm sorry we love you i'm on
but i gotta go with papa feige on this
one then on to a post-credits scene
featuring the turn of ariane my head as
dodc agent cleary from spider-man no way
home last seen interrogating peter
parker nj ned and aunt may before matt
murdock was able to get the dodc to drop
the charges cleary and agent dever now
see footage of kamala and decide to
bring her in meaning this series is
going to shed some more light on what
the dodc is up to their connections to
nick fury and sword and hopefully
confirm my scroll suspicions that agent
clary might be a skrull connected with
marvel's secret invasion plans his
concerned look suggests he has seen this
kind of technology before and if cleary
is a skrull he might be seeing some cree
weapons tech emerging in one of the cree
sleeper cells nick fury aka the skrull
talos mentioned in spider-man far from
home remember cree and skrulls are
forever at war something we'll probably
learn more about in secret invasion and
the next title kamala khan is going to
appear in the marvels so maybe now this
look is telling us that cleary is seeing
some evidence of the cree sleeper cell
with the creed genetic experiments
called inhumans which might be what
kamala khan's pakistani ancestors were
we will see and i'm not sure how much to
read into this but under steve's phone
on her desk are wanted flyers for a
caucasian woman 5 8 brown hair 180
pounds wanted in connection to a double
homicide on july 12
1979 in the municipal graveyard 1979 is
ages ago in mcu history and my only
guess based on a graveyard slaying is
that this might tie into blades somehow
there are some photos on the board
showing some folks from older eras maybe
vampires are on their docket too that's
everything i spotted in this great first
episode of miss marvel follow me on
instagram and twitter avos new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you